Why don't you understand?
slipping as the like, some
Sleepless.
Is the noun.
I want to break right
now.
Write down right now.
That means like to take
notes.
Call Peter painter, that Drew
the professor is riding on
the bars are cool things
and things that are in
his life. When you write
down amazing, you are like
riding on your notebook.
Brides always afraid of work.
I know it's perfect because
like that's the idea of
phrasal verbs for the ride
down. So we are like,
we have his own the
two particles like we have
the verb and we have
the verb working together to
have a different meaning.
Do they have the right?
Which is nice. Cuz you're
right. We have down there.
Like, sit down right there.
Bus is an attack because
they're afraid of us are
together. It has a different
meaning.
So your braces listener, I
start writing down whatever the
truth is the speaking or
writing on the Ride Board.
Lunch break easily pissed. I
start writing it right now
and we're going to whatever
the public speaking or writing
on the white barge, okay,
okay,
Is there a gift? Cuz
my, my paper space to
write, write. Write, write Bernie
just, did you just pay
for? It is like, just
is very cheap for the
user is Right? Barge.
Set alarm.
Your professor posted on campus.
I asked Professor to to
post cuz you told me
before they call the Old
Republic.
Peter and his March.
Okay.